well the seven states that use water
from the Colorado River almost reach an
agreement before another Federal
deadline six of those States including
us here in Nevada we agreed on various
ways to conserve on Monday they sent a
letter to the U.S Bureau of Reclamation
which manages the river outlining the
plan but the state that uses the most
water California refused to sign on
Nevada U.S senator Jackie Rosen
what I do want to say not just to
California but to all of us we are in
this together the west coast of the
United States many of the states have
had persistent or extreme drought for
many years now we are in this together
water is the source of life
well by California not signing the
agreement all of the states are at risk
of the federal government stepping in to
tell us how to reduce our consumption